first like 20 years of my life my
biggest fing fear was gaining weight I
spent so many years of my life freaking
out over you know gaining weight or not
fitting in the same pair of pants or
whatever and anytime I would try and
work out to be healthy it was always
always always always because I wanted to
lose weight weight loss culture Ed
culture diet culture all of it is rooted
in fat phobia because our country is
rooted in fat phobia yeah back when she
used to go to the gym and watch what she
ate and work out and everything that was
back she was doing that to lose weight
but now that she doesn't want to lose
weight and she is now an anti fatphobia
activist look how happy she is doesn't
she seem well adjusted isn't she
thriving and living her best life thank
goodness she gave up on that